[Music]
welcome back to careful boards where
we like to suck jesus
who wasn't about it you didn't say it
that was your idea and you just said
your attack i didn't know we were gonna
say together i thought you're gonna tell
me to say what do we do and i said and
i'll be like i like keep it in there
here we go welcome back to careful boys
where joe likes to suck on dick oh
oh good yeah i mean we're down that's
fine like that's totally fine man that's
awesome hey that's awesome yeah it's
better oh wait was that nick's line no i
took your line sorry it's [ __ ] up
because you knew the prompter says nick
and then it says yeah so yeah okay okay
okay okay
cut that one here we go yeah welcome
back to careful boys where nick likes to
suck dick hey oh wait because it rhymes
with my knees
really good nick sucks dick
okay hold on let's wait time let's try
one more time but everybody says the
same thing after i point to nick okay
nick sucks
my
by the way nick is married to a woman
and then everybody says sucks dick
because it rhymes it rhymes no you're
just tricking me
but it was just a fraud under the hood
it was all over zoom dude come on
[ __ ]
see you guys
nick likes to suck dick what's up segway
i'm not i'm not saying it's you but i
gotta share an interesting story so
obviously you know you guys have been
clowning me with the whole jabba no one
clowns
this is just truth it's just we're a
sports team we like to [ __ ] around
nothing is meant to be taken oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah
i'm not going to do this
it's cool guys i'm not offended no
because if i see jab walks on the
streets i'ma [ __ ] them yeah dude
i got your back i told you we have to
fight them when we see them
i got your back just the way i didn't
have two drive-bys for you dude
[Laughter]
dude
he tagged up the store he shot up mgm
accidentally killed tupac all right
again so uh i was teaching this class on
monday right this is where it comes from
i was teaching this class on my day and
then you know after you teach class uh
you know some of us are
fortunate enough to stick around and and
talk to a couple people that you know
want to take classes and there's one
kind of um
semi awkward dude who uh chills at the
at the back and he waits for everybody
to finish the thing right so literally
by the end of everybody going out taking
photos it's just me and this dude in the
in the room he comes up to me and he
doesn't do what anybody else does he's
just kind of like hey man
i was cool man i was like all right
thanks dude
and then he's like um can we take a
photo i'm like yeah but everybody else
took a photo with you you know like a
selfie and stuff so why don't we take
one in the mirror i'm like okay
sure let's
let's innovate all right so we look at
the mirror and he's like hey yo is it
cool if i like you know flip it off and
i'm like
sure man like whatever so obviously like
i was originally like you know just
doing my kinder bag and he's like can i
flip it off i was like oh sure yeah man
so i think you want you to do it to her
no no well i mean i just didn't i just
didn't think about it and then i said he
flips off right
take the photo i'm like cool man thanks
for coming class and then uh he tagged
me later in the photo on ig stories
text me this photo it's a photo of us
in the mirror i'm standing there like
this he's flipping off and then he
writes
he writes [ __ ] jabberwockies on it this
[ __ ]
yo that means he's a jk news fan that
took your class probably doesn't even
dance right we don't know he's a jk news
fan no no no no no no
listen listen listen come on look listen
listen come on what is what happened he
[ __ ] watched the show he planned this
[ __ ] out he probably doesn't
even dance he went to go see your ass
waited the whole entire time [ __ ]
sweating balls just so you could take
that picture
and say [ __ ] jabbawockeez did he dance
was he did he took the class he took a
class the best part is please somebody
just take that out of context and just
have anthony saying [ __ ] that boy
it's so easy he's been so easy you used
to have to take multiple clips of him in
different shirts or something i got a
question i got a question for you for
two words
why why are you upset
with someone that got your back so hard
yeah dude he [ __ ] loves ninjas bro
no no no so so anthony basically saying
like hey ryder dies like go [ __ ]
yourself
no guys okay what are you really trying
to say you got to clarify first of all
you know okay to like multiple dance
moves what do you want from us whether
you follow jk news or not nothing
nothing yet you know it might be funny
it's all good innocent you know i'm very
happy i don't know anybody that doesn't
follow jk news that hates the job of
walkies everyone loves the jabways of
course of course they're probably
listening to your trolling ass my crypto
corners are like [ __ ] jab blocks oh no
stop it
okay truth is the only reason why these
guys say is because not true they love
them right i literally will never go to
jeff walker show in my life ever dude
and i would protest outside of it
we're gonna go next week actually i
can't wait we have signs dude so of
course this guy tags me in it i give you
two guesses what the signs say
i've been to the five of them every time
they have a different
uh
five shows
so i i'm like i know why you guys need
masks that's cause you're ashamed of
yourself
yeah i go there to heckle yeah it's
cause you're ashamed of your dancing
i'm messing this guy back and i
literally say yo man i don't think
that's cool to write that by the way yo
keep the jokes in-house bro yes please
that is the problem i think sometimes in
all seriousness i think sometimes they
get they feel so close to us that they
forget that like too close yeah they're
too close like yes you did hear the
conversation but you're not really in
the [ __ ] job you can't just go out to
your head it's a random strategy yes you
can it's a [ __ ] dance crew you guys
are [ __ ] stupid
you can literally say [ __ ] jabbawockeez
as much as you want it's america
but i swear i did have the notion i had
this random feeling not random this
feeling of guilt i was like i need a
[ __ ] god jk needs to actually tell
people straight yeah i actually really
like the job oh please this is
propaganda this was exactly this is
exactly like [ __ ] like probably six
years or whatever the [ __ ] when bart
roasts me bart rose thank god to him
i've never roasted you
jokes about how we never won [ __ ] right
and now for three years second place
which is i'm very proud of you guys
hey dude second place is awesome yeah
you said what you guys didn't even win
hey dude silver is cool shut the [ __ ] up
people love it it's ethereum baby
and then i got like three to four years
three to four years of people commenting
out of context or running up to me
telling me about how i didn't win so i
get i gave you people read up too i gave
you interaction very good okay
engagement it's called engagement
i think like we got to keep these jokes
in house please you [ __ ] bro i don't
go outside of this place and say [ __ ]
jabbawockeez i do i like murder accounts
i do i guess i'm right or died though
you know what you guys could go tell
anthony [ __ ] jabberwockies but don't go
publicly tell people
and don't go tell don't go to other
kenjas and say you guys were number two
they don't [ __ ] get the joke off the
record is on the record as a careful i
love the jabberwockies i've always been
inspired by them but
you know what it's her clip
you know you know you know the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] is is
is your other members that don't know
[ __ ] about what's happening in this in
this like they'll go to mike's song and
then they'll be like you're number two
and it's like he doesn't get the [ __ ]
joke he doesn't even know that [ __ ]
happens that [ __ ] definitely i've
been in a group you've never been sad
from something like that not mad he's
angry korean dude
he punched the guy in the face like what
the [ __ ] is happening
like i apologize to him no no it's not
it's not even like it's just more of
those out of context right if like we're
chilling in a group and then somebody
comes up throws out the inside joke and
then other kanjis are there they don't
understand all the [ __ ] like yo
[ __ ] just huh
okay okay wait that's doable i dare be
able to come up to us as a group if you
say to me i'm like hi you're a jks fan
it doesn't really hurt yeah but you come
to me and a bunch of other kids they're
gonna do it though [ __ ] just i would
crack up okay
all right all right we do we have an
alternative now what if fans come up to
the kinjaz as a group and they go man
[ __ ] the jabberwockies would you guys
all go that's whack dude that'd be wet
what that's [ __ ] hilarious
that's your guy's inside joke between
you guys you know that okay first of all
no
are the rest of the kitchen
what is that better [ __ ] kendra's a [ __ ]
jab watch yeah which one do you want us
to do because it's either one dude you
can't you can't make us get rid of both
you're gonna be a good leader you're
gonna tell me why i should like the
jabberwocky because so far i've just
heard a bunch of hate
the burden of proof is on you
i just heard nothing but [ __ ] handle the
truth man yeah literally like all i've
heard is how they're the shittiest dance
crew they won't show their faces because
they're ashamed of themselves
that's all i've heard and they're a
bunch of merch salesmen
innovators of the game they barely have
soup i heard yeah they have no soup
that's us we don't have soup we're
soupless noodles oh yeah you guys have
superman
just yesterday or last week you were
talking about they don't have to make
noodles
i did say that
outside this room sticks to the [ __ ]
kendra's narrative it saves my
self-preservation and makes me wait what
about your other kin just they start fun
fam dude i say [ __ ] the kendra
don't [ __ ] the other kin just
how did the other kid just take it
though when they get like random
comments like that on their page or
isn't there like 40 of you guys no i
don't honestly i don't think
honestly if a fan genuinely just went to
like mike song's page and just said [ __ ]
ninjas and obviously he's not here all
the time yeah honestly i would love mike
to just rip that full [ __ ] like it
doesn't matter i'd be like hey jk fan
get out of here dude like that's that's
wrong because it's weird that's socially
wrong you know what i'm saying socially
wrong about it today's video is brought
to you by upstart if you look at your
credit card statement and you're like ah
what the hell you are not alone that's
why upstart is here to help you see the
light at the end of the tunnel upstart
is the fast and easy way to pay off all
your debt with a personal loan all
online whether you're paying off credit
cards consolidating high interest debt
or funding personal expenses over half a
million people have used upstart to get
one fixed monthly payment upside knows
you're more than just your credit score
so is now expanding access to affordable
credit unlike other lenders upstart
considers your income and current
employment to help you find a smarter
rate for your loan with a five minute
rate check you can see your rate upfront
for loans from 1 000 up to 50 000
and receive your funds as soon as one
business day after being accepted find
out how upstart can lower your monthly
payments today by going to upstart.com
off the record that's upstart.com off
the record and don't forget to use that
url so they know that we sent you loan
amounts will be determined by your
credit income and other certain
information that you put on your loan
application make sure you go to
upstart.com off the record but they say
to me
yeah then i'm like yo i honestly look
down like yo this is a jk fan like i
i'll like it probably
but if you say [ __ ] jello this is a
random public forum without context
people don't understand what that is you
know what i'm saying i think you're
gonna spend
[ __ ] wasn't that the way public
bathrooms are you go on the gas station
they just have something on the wall i
don't know what that means but it's
there they also have a hole drilled so
if you want to stick your dick in here
just to a public bathroom well you said
public forum you know so i'm like that's
that's your public foreign
public bathroom public forum glory hole
if anything is a public bathroom i think
jk is and i stand proudly let's go yeah
keep the riding in the bathroom you know
what i'm saying
this is literally the second time that
i've had to come on here and talk about
how the fans be going out of context
your problem i have to say and i mean
this as your friend i love you i really
do love you um is that you had a plan
today and we want to just wreck it
and it really is that simple as a friend
as soon as i see oh cool you wanted to
build your little lego house [ __ ] your
lego wow
again some more blind boy [ __ ] dude hey
what you didn't build a lego house
what did you guys have couldn't afford
it dude oh you guys
asian kids had lincoln logs that was it
yeah
lincoln
would you just get that lincoln
get the [ __ ] out here dude
we were [ __ ] busy taking chopsticks
and super gluing them together with
elmer's glue or whatever i remember
making a cabin out of chopsticks
popsicle sticks yeah yeah popsicle
sticks was also just a little bit
chopsticks was easier and more
accessible than you used to put your
helix recruited legos just buy legos
what the [ __ ] are you talking about you
can buy boxes of popsicle sticks just to
even build a house the popsicle sticks
came from like the nurse's office stole
the popsicle sticks and then they're
sucked that is right yeah because they
do it
oh yeah yeah true good house
really understood why i don't know
for the ton
yeah so they can see your tongue
depressor yeah so they can see the back
of the throat see if it's inflamed or if
they got you oh gosh i always remember
just putting on [ __ ] like little eyes
that have the shaky pupils in them yeah
oh yeah wiggly or uh googly eyes yeah
googly eyes that's what it's called the
point is
[ __ ] hinges okay honestly though i think
you have a really good sense of humor
because i have buddies in the fitness
realm so i had a buddy that worked for
another company
and i thought it would be funny because
they were beefing with another company
right
so my buddy when we're at the fit expo i
was like come over stand right here real
quick and i know how bad the beef is
like they [ __ ] hate each other if
they saw each other they would just
start throwing wait what is fitness beef
they're just like like your biceps not
as big yeah we're not hot enough an
example would be this an example would
be this like let's say someone
it actually invented something and
patented it
and that's part of their company another
company just comes and rips and starts
selling oh that's legit yeah yeah so
there's like there's beef like like
there's no i says and then i would get
my buddy to stand
at his boss's opposing company and do a
quick real photo shoot and i would send
it to his boss and like yo i don't know
what the hell this guy's doing
[Laughter]
the way you do
props to you for having a good sense of
humor one of my best pals his name is
full mag on youtube now his name is
richard ryan and he shoots [ __ ] in slow
motion like with 50 cows and all kinds
of [ __ ] super sick
but there's another guy named fbs russia
who was coming up in the game right i
remember and then but fps russia used to
live in georgia and he would [ __ ] do
all kinds of craziest [ __ ] that was
unsafe as [ __ ] and then my friend
richard was doing it right and like
doing sick [ __ ] but then this other guy
was getting more views and so i used to
call out fps russian at him every time
and i'd be like richard ryan shit's way
[ __ ] better than fbs russia's doing
hack ass [ __ ] in georgia
pretending like he's in la shack yeah
yeah and he with a fake accent because
he wasn't even really russian right what
he wasn't even obvious back then even
but but his fans were like what are you
[ __ ] talking about of course he's
rushing i got a pajama i thought he was
russian too until like this guy youtube
we met him we were under the same
network and then i was like oh [ __ ] i've
heard this nice guy
went to jail
he went to jail for having a fake accent
no it's a bunch of other bunch of bunch
of boys manager died or something i
think it was like he committed suicide
but no one knows this is escalating
i know he went to jail for like it was
like a marijuana position and like uh
like i think there might have been some
ffl issues because he had a bunch of
like things you're not really supposed
to have but like the the legalities of
it were a little dubious there's a whole
there's nobody you drove a tank through
a mcdonald's drive through somehow
that's dubious as [ __ ]
the point is i have my burrows back yeah
and so i understand the jk fan want to
say yo [ __ ] some jab walkies up okay
because they're trying to have your back
they love you dude
this dude was probably not even a dancer
he took your class and he waited hours
through the [ __ ] what what through
the snow
this is the only way we can salvage this
your next dance class all of us
collectively go go there and the whole
time we're just yelling [ __ ] jabba
right that's your salvage plan yeah like
so it's just us i want to get a [ __ ]
jabberwocky's dummy and light it on fire
outside
the king just laughs
the only reason why this existing can be
funny it still comes from and why i
laugh is still the fact that they're my
homies and i really really respect them
but goddamn out of context i for sure
will by the end of this year have to
apologize for something
i swear to god jk fans going over there
like do they know do they know yet i
have no idea but that's the problem if
there's something doesn't get pushed in
more positive momentum i for sure i'm
going to even start because we're trying
to make anthony sweat dude we're going
to make himself
it started because they lost the jab
walkies they started they lost right
no they left the quest crew we lost the
quest crew
[ __ ] quest crew
wait what were we doing [ __ ] quest crew
oh
hey
my bad guys i'll take the blunder on
this one this one's on me
i'll take full blame jabbawockeez i'm
sorry we're trying to make anthony sweat
hey but also [ __ ] the chat milwaukee's
dog we're doubling down and quest crew
dude first of all javelin it's funny
because we have quests coming up in here
wait so ryan mate is quest group
i've been helping him with crypto
[ __ ] ryan mma i'm never i'm gonna tell
him to buy some stupid [ __ ] like sheep
he takes it
he'll buy it too he buys whatever the
[ __ ] i say
beatrix was quest too he's stupid
[ __ ]
he gets rich as [ __ ]
because that what happened to ryan anime
that would happen to ryan
anything that guy touches the goal of
this [ __ ] guy
he's talented yeah right so he's so yeah
he's with the talented crew like that
you guys thought you were really going
to win
by the way i have to say no you can't
even you have a straight face
in all honesty i do have to say the
quest is [ __ ] amazing
those guys know how to [ __ ] dance
dude
i'm like they don't need to go and so
you think you kiss because they can
dance
so you know you can dance
we got your back so hard we have your
back bro all right yeah yeah we're you
ride or die dude like we just want to
fight give him somebody to fight
then it's for sure [ __ ] questions
these [ __ ] [ __ ] beat me in
abdc [ __ ] those people yo anthony said
both [ __ ] jab walking and
we got the bingo baby it's over all
right next next time next careful boys
we're going to invite a jabberwocky and
then we're going to have to settle the
beef here yeah i don't even know what
they look like
they wear masks they're cowards bro
you're getting a random filipino guy
it's like he's the devil yeah i'm
filipino with a weird haircut
that's quest group
that's question yeah ryan anime is a job
walking too isn't he i don't let you say
ryan anime ryan anime i think he is a
jabberwocky he has his name ryan anime
ry anime ryan may right and oh no you're
the difference dude it's ryan anime bro
how do you spot a jabberwocky man
probably wearing a white mask is it like
uh probably running from a lady
[Laughter]
do they smell like cigarettes like how
do i
how do i tell them from other people
a filipino guy smells like cigarettes or
something
he's got the sickest shoes for sure he's
got something he's got a bucket hat no
he had one of these yeah yeah you got a
bunker hat you got a real dope style
shoes scuffle shoes i think he has a
little mask on the back
because they won't represent that
air
can we end this article yet no we have
30 seconds 30 seconds dude get it all
out guys
this is our last time
that's how dedicated our fans are dude
they [ __ ] took a dance class so they
could take a picture with this fool and
say [ __ ] jeff and he hadn't even planned
out to flip off the [ __ ] and he
deceived it
thought of this dude and anthony's like
you know what i'm gonna do i'll go on jk
and i'll lecture them about this
in front of the group who literally
can't wait to
put a [ __ ] hammer ball-peen hammer to
your balls
every single time you show your face
here we will [ __ ] hammer your balls
like that
i do have to say though that [ __ ] is
because we're friends all of you guys
out there that don't [ __ ] know him
[ __ ] that's wild right
that's the best way to say it that's
wild that is why that's spicy [ __ ]
because you guys gotta cut that out man
i know it's like spicy spicy food dude
if you get [ __ ] up that's not on us
man what's your final words to the fans
watching [ __ ] the fans sorry job in
advance i'll talk to you guys later
so defeated
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you